you
hi everyone it's Jerry Aman leeches org
and I'm playing a 15-2 game let's start
out with E for all right let's see what
we get in this one hopefully some just
gonna say hopefully not the Sicilian I
try and mix it up I think the last two
standard games yeah it's a delayed alp
and let's just start out with this on e6
I guess we're gonna go into an open
instead of a c3 okay well at least it's
a different with that so let's see
Bishop b5 d4 oh let's go into a Bishop
b5 line
yeah now feeling too too wild so I don't
know if I want to go straight into an
open Sicilian so let's see Bishop d7
night here okay so let's see I guess
what's soon to happen is a question
thrown to my bishop
let's see castles probably just castles
and on a6 take the knight uh yeah I mean
I don't know Bishop to Bishop to d3 is
maybe a move although there is b5 + c4
ideas I'll probably just end up taking
the night so we're gonna soon have an
imbalance if given an opportunity I'll
play rook e1 and then on a6 I could play
to f1 but uh there really isn't a
conveniently tree here this may turn
into if I try for Bishop d3 it may turn
into like a Spanish opening by
transposition c3 tucking it back but I
believe I'm Bishop d3 there's b5 and on
c3 there would be c4
it's very awkward to obstruct your
Center pond but uh uh yeah okay I guess
I'm gonna be pretty quick to give up the
bishop pair in this one okay so now what
need to be delicate with my light
squares for one I won't be so quick to
move my pond that's in the center on the
light square need some light square
control
am I really concerned about Bishop g4
pinning by night I don't think so
my first thought is d4 which is maybe a
bit counterintuitive to open the
position when you're without the bishop
pair but on the other side of things
let's see how are we looking timewise in
the position I still need one pawn move
two three four before I have a direct
connection between my rooks black has
yet to do anything with their Kings side
probably d4 c4 I don't know about c4
trying to get a grip over d5 yeah let's
let's open it up a little bit okay
they're very quick now niter Queen
normally there'd be a bit of a you don't
really want to recapture with your Queen
because of a queen Knight developing
with tempo but we really don't have that
situation hello although on Queen takes
d4 Bishop g4 moves could be a little bit
annoying although I guess I could just
scoot back a step and defend laterally
Ellis let's retake with the Queen so
where's this Bishop gonna go we know
where the King Knights gonna go where's
the dark square Bishop going to go go
forward the fianchetto
um regarding my seat pon I don't know if
I still want to do this or not
c4 Knight c3 or an immediate Knight c3
okay this move tells me that they won't
be going with the kingside fiend keto
they've opened the door in this
direction so also I really can't play
Bishop f4 to target this pun because of
a fork hmm let's see Knight c3 c4 rook
d1 all candidate moves for me I'm not
quite sure what my knight on c3 is doing
excuse me I think c3 Knight f6 here's
another way to look at it on Knight c3
Knight f6 maybe I could hit with E 5 and
on a recapture this bishop will be
hunted down I don't think I really
gotten anything out of this opening
night c3 rook d1 I'm not really crashing
through on d6 I don't know if I should
really be piling up
hmm what else to consider here
I don't think Bishop g5 pinning the
night one sits on f6 would really be an
inconvenience I kind of feel like I want
to insert this c4 move first because
well I see the c2 upon obstructing with
my knight when once the rook plays here
it becomes a little bit awkward to
defend this pawn
whereas if he's on c4 or I could I could
always reinforce it with b3 having the
pawn on c4 though it does it does allow
for an eventual b5 strike I think I do
want to get that in though I'm gonna
invest the time to get that move in
let's go with c4 Knight c3 okay this is
a weak square in b6 but I don't know
that that's something I could really
take advantage of sometimes this but the
bishops there to watch over a night on
b6 would only would be the really the
only piece that could maybe cause black
some inconvenience
they're still not doing anything with
their queenside also I may need to be a
bit cautious about the b5 strike like
night here
ripped to c8 if I play b3 than be five
hits in my knight on c3 is uh it's
vulnerable so maybe in other words I
shouldn't be so quick to play Knight c3
also maybe I could go for b3 Bishop b2
there's already one door open for him
but maybe he's better placed on the long
diagonal or maybe even Bishop e3 is an
idea with rook d1 I think eventually
I'll have to play b3 so I should
probably do it right now I'm vulnerable
for a little bit along the main diagonal
myself with the rook on a1 this stuff
but Bishop b2 will be coming soon let's
do that
let's see what black does I haven't done
anything with their Kings side yet well
they've moved their epon but still need
both minor pieces out I may want to
retain some flexibility with my c1
bishop although I am pretty sure it does
want to go to be to a head in mind first
rook to d1 he pretty much knows his
place my bishop on the other hand yeah I
mean with this diagonal weakened opened
up here he's pretty much locked into
going to a B to b5 might hit mm-hmm and
when it does I think I have to take and
I will be in inviting a piece forward in
a position where it strikes so I have to
be wary of that my opponent is not so
quick to just go with the natural moves
it's clear they've already shown by
their early moves they have plans in
mind of this b5 strike two to deploy the
Queen to the C file early and well
they're trying to be disruptive to what
it is I want to do they're not just uh
they're not just focused on developing
their own pieces in independent of what
I'm doing it's uh you know they're
they're taking into account my moves and
what it is I want to do that I believe
Knight c3 would have run into some
trouble as natural move as that is
instead of b3 rook c8 b3 and then B five
and I'm in some hot water I believe so
it's important to be aware of the strike
b5 d5
this is the more difficult of the two to
get in because of having the two pawns
Queen its b5 that's already available on
rook c8 I think just Bishop to b2 right
away a bit happy to see my opponent
spending some time I've already invested
7 after only nine moves so let's see
Knight f6 rook c8 b5 right here here
Knight f6 I'd love to see a move like
this get that night into d5
that's not gonna happen I think earlier
I was referencing if Bishop here I'd
want to maybe drop back to defend my
knight I certainly want to stay off of
this square here anticipating the b5
capture capture I'd end up in a skewer
but as it's interesting Wow that doesn't
seem right moves like this or shot down
with e5 by the way that seems a bit off
if I'm being completely honest I mean
how where's the night heading a 5 Wow
I don't think that that's right look at
my bishop here because night here you
notice the pressure against g7 how does
the bishop now develop and I'm guessing
that the idea is here with the temple
against the Queen and the knight here I
could take and double the pawns but I
don't think I will because of the the
nice possibilities that are available
for the bishop but instead I'll think
about moving the knight and then
actually grabbing a tempo against the
knight on e5
hmm so probably Queen III staying out
for the light squares keeping an eye on
this square maybe another way to view it
um let's see yeah let's go here oh well
no and that's not a big lead one move
away from being connected there are two
moves away but they're still having to
solve some problems here can't do a
Bishop e7 so easily now so how to
complete King side development with this
idea of transferring the King Knight to
the Queen side again I'm expecting
Knight to e5 hmm I 95 I was thinking
Knight d4 with f4 in mind I have to be
careful of this as soon as you touch
that F pawn you're vulnerable your King
on both diagonal and rank 95 92 with the
idea to take in the night f3 you more
positional approach I think
no no I'm guessing you have to block
this diagonal somehow so oh that seems
very very very slow very very slow okay
I may already have some ideas of
throwing my knight into this square no I
don't want to block that bishop so quick
though hmm
this I feel like it should be punished
somehow I feel like there should be some
way to take advantage of this very slow
move the Kings stolen castle dime
castled my queen is opposite their king
he'll look to try and open up the
position with e5 in fact maybe this
should be capturing my attention why not
e5 really really why not just my moment
open up the position fee five Knight
takes pawn takes Bishop takes Bishop d6
they are hitting here
what else to consider I don't have much
fear of this do I um hmm I really don't
want to block my bishop so quick
'if I've pawn takes and Knight takes
yeah I mean they could go Queen side as
well
well that's uh let's play Knight here I
just I want to develop and I want to
stay out of my bishop sway so let's see
they still aren't doing anything to
solve and their problem Bishop let's say
how to successfully develop him are they
going to go Queen side if they got Queen
side I mean they have some weaknesses
here clearly b6 also their king and
queen are on the same file so can
imagine a move like rook to see one
summer up to see one is probably banking
a tempo at some point hmm I will take
that pawn on g7 if the bishop moves I
know it gives out an open G file but uh
I'm gonna grab that pawn I'm gonna take
that guy I'll probably devote a couple
of minutes to decide but in the end
they'll probably take it anyhow
candidate moves I'm still thinking are
95 castles on castles rook c1 I guess
I'm not sure what rook is better
probably go with the a rook the F rook
may want to play to d1 so I have that
set up with the rooks on Knight to e5 do
I capture the night and then play Knight
to f1
hmm or avoid the exchange with its
Knight d4 and then think about f4 f5
stuff again some care is needed if I do
go forward this idea of f4 95 takes
takes I don't know how how much of an
inconvenience it is to have those double
def pawns oh actually you know what I
could do on 95 I could take in on pawn
takes I have this move Queen g3 which is
very good it's a very simple approach
keeping the structure as is targeting
the pawn a second time and exerting
pressure on g7 Bishop d6 I take g7 on f6
that weakens g6 the king is in check and
running for his life ninety five is not
a good idea
ooh now I wish my knight was still on b1
so he could get to d5 but I may actually
run in Reverse just to get to that juicy
square can I do that I almost certainly
can and should go for it right away um
let's go for it also when it does hit it
hits hard with the tempo so I'm under
developing but I really want to make use
of the weakness that has been created
with e5 so now now they could play
Bishop e7 but my knight is going to be a
real beast an intolerable piece really
and you know I'm expecting this and then
I could always take gain a tempo against
the knight and maybe even well the
bishop would be here I was thinking I
could with my pawn here the pawn on e5
would be pinned
I could for the moment make use of v5
and then jump into f5 which is another
square to look into you know these ideas
getting into the light squares basically
also if we do have this bishop for night
exchange there's no longer the bishop
pair for black clearly and I could start
to think about the position I could try
to let's say make use of the fact that I
have the better bishop good bishop
versus bad bishop situations so if I
could somehow you know the imagine these
pieces exchanged and these nights I'd
have a good Bishop versus a bad bishop
or even a situation where these two are
exchanged and the bishop and Knight are
exchanged I could have an excellent
night versus a bad Bishop basically I
don't want to allow this dark square
bishop now that e5 has been played I
don't want to allow this bishop to
exchange himself off for any of my minor
pieces I'm looking to play against their
dark square Bishop let's get here Bishop
e6 I think is mandatory have to be a
little bit careful of Bishop g5 but I
have my knight here for the moment
where's this Knight gonna go is another
interesting question you know what I may
want to do I may want to prep Knight
here with rook c1 first so that when he
does play here can't be taken because
there'd be a pin against the knight
let's see I'd like to have a knight here
could I get this in that takes forever
hmmm I think I want to have the C file
open up let's go with this rook I think
there's a reason to keep him defended
I'm expecting maybe a queen here to get
off of this file or even on time 95 okay
I should probably go in 95 should I just
I don't know that I want to capture on
d5 with the pawn another change of plans
here rook to d1 or how about Queen here
actually no let's play it let's play it
in the C file enough shifting gears
let's make use of what's going to now be
the only open file I'm expecting Bishop
takes Knight and their knight probably
has to go back home I think he's a bit
stranded if he goes to us
a5 or b4 he probably ends up getting
trapped yeah he gets trapped I think
immediately with a 3 or B 4 depending on
where he goes can black really live with
the the knight on the square I was
saying I don't want to trade a piece I
don't want to capture this guy but maybe
I could think about taking him out and
then targeting d6 I could shift gears
let's come back over here now maybe I
will end up taking with the rook here a
little a lot of change of plans here but
I still I believe maintain an advantage
I don't know what this really amounts to
after rook to b8 I'm not sure I really
passed
the two-word test let's just say I don't
know how to you know now what after
Knight b6 rippy 8 now what I see I see
it as a situation my queen is tethered
to the defense of the night ok positions
clearly opening up some I don't think I
want to allow f4 let's take him even
reposition like this ok Bishop e3 has my
attention that might be something Bishop
g4 getting a sharp here another approach
is Knight d2 to e4 it's a bit more solid
Knight d2 there's Bishop g5 maybe that's
ok I just play Queen e2 there's no night
before I have that covered I'm going to
look to anchor my knight on e4
I feel a little bit vulnerable for just
a moment but uh I think I should be
alright
have this square covered maybe their
night still goes there though okay
they've done good to get very active
there they didn't they weren't so quick
to give up their light square Bishop 94
happening soon Knight d4 hits wit's
tempo I'm pretty much locked into taking
him maybe I hunt that pawn right down
though without Knight to f3 but Bishop
g4 that is a very annoying pin hmm I
have a knight
in blacks position he's within checking
distance currently the Queen does a good
job boxing him out given time I'd like
94 and f3 hmm
challenging my strong Knight well yeah
I'll let you take me I'll run it like
that if you want you help me to improve
one of my pieces so now this is hit oh
this is really giving up the light
squares if there isn't something
immediate this is a big problem for
black I believe f2 is sensitive but okay
yeah f2 is sensitive but how about
simply f3 focusing on these lights in
the light square control yeah that's
that's the correct way to do it allow
upon to defend the pawn okay so this is
really probably going to a collapse very
soon Bishop here and I don't think he
could defend that pawn again bishop a3
and I think it's broken down have a good
versus bad Bishop situation I have light
square control bishops around a guard
dark Bishop e3 and house d6 defended
this is a possible check but I don't
really see what the great follow up is
Bishop takes e5 isn't working they have
enough defense of the rook on e d8 let's
go for this also after he falls this is
vulnerable I'm not sure how to take
probably with the rook I'm not sure
both are appealing actually I want to
take hits the rook I'd like to kick him
off of this it's a F file I know that
there's nothing happening you know he's
defended but still I'd much rather have
the rook stare at his own pond than one
of my pawns just in case so I may want
to do this rook here here and then back
up to b4 and then focus on new weakness
the new target Bishop f4 and then Queen
here might be an idea Oh
offering a clean exchange that honestly
feels like
I don't know it makes life a lot easier
for me just take the Queen right I don't
see any reason not to let's just
exchange Queens I'm gonna be winning a
material soon so I want to try and keep
it as clean as possible I was thinking
this and unchecking g2 about Bishop
there actually maybe that's still fine
yeah you know on bishop check King here
there's e4 g3 Bishop check King g2 let's
see yeah that pond is hit three times
gonna go with this
I just want to scoop my king up to g2
tuck them in okay just defend f3 and you
can't save this still you could play
Bishop here but I still have enough on
it okay now I'm gonna take with the
bishop because it's hitting the rook
it's hitting the pawn and he's a passed
pawn now I think just Bishop takes or
actually let's do let's just take here
first and Bishop takes yeah I should go
a little bit faster um this was not good
technique what I just did there was very
bad yeah this was really bad what I just
did here not good at all that was
terrible that was really really bad what
I just did there
I should have exchanged one pair of
rooks still better but that was very
very poor very very poor I want to
anchor my bishop next that's a regroup
here
role-reversal have my pawn defend my
bishop and seek one exchange I'd
actually like to have my pawn up here so
I could play here safely maybe I should
have done this first there less than 10
minutes or less than 10 seconds let's
get a quick move in here give a check on
f6 and actually double up back let's
let's take here actually let's get rid
of this pawn so I can't get play here
enough to worry about mating Nets let's
just defend everything oh ok they're
down on time but this is of course
winning here these are three connected
passed pawns I'm uh I don't know I'm a
bit upset with how I converted that that
was really really poor we'll have a look
at it with the computer but right here
um Bishop takes was fine this was not
fine
it'll still be winning but this is just
you know this matter of technique type
situation I'm allowing this rook to
avoid exchange pretty easily
I should go straight in win another pawn
bishop takes here right away up clear
two pawns and keep him around actually
he's not no need to exchange him off I
guess I was a bit fearful in the back of
my mind I had it you know I'm gonna take
here just to keep my pawn structure
intact the UH like a pawn duo that allow
takes and then then have my pawned split
but I should just be taking here not
here because of rook takes Bishop takes
and then my rook is Luke hanging on d1
but like I did in the game Bishop takes
pawn only right now in this position
instead of first taking on b5 and then I
believe it would have been much easier
let's go into the analysis that's what
it okay both of them are popping up but
let's let's take it from the top here
let's see so yeah just a slight pull
ever so slight 97 it's not really what
does it like yeah it's pointing out
Knight Bishop e7 Knight f6 that seemed
just quite natural and good also yeah
let me just quickly highlight this idea
here with Queen c7 Knight c3 is this a
problem it's suggesting rook c8 and now
after b3 b5 correct B five hits and now
what am i doing yes it's becoming a bit
awkward it has it as zero evaluation
wise but this is very awkward I can't
take
hmm so have to be aware of that this
pressure on the C file the b5 strike v3
at a half pond advantage you know I mean
the I think it was just the wrong idea
with the kingside pieces going for is
too too long-winded a plan okay we need
three h6 in accuracy was h6 what did it
suggest the f6 if you have to play off
six this is totally wrong no way that's
just such an ugly move weakening e6 and
weakening the Kings physician once he's
castled the dog you know the rank yeah
so the wrong way I think to organize the
kingside pieces is the short story does
like this idea to go back and b5 b5
could have hit huh that's what it's
suggesting right here suppose B five
hits what am i doing I'm going straight
in for that don't know that it would
have done that I was I think I might
have taken and then played Knight c3
yeah that's another way to do it okay so
there was at least I know this is a very
weakening move and it is being suggested
by the computer one of them
it was just popping up there for a
moment but uh certainly important that
if black does go go forward with this
move then maybe maybe that's what they
were waiting for actually come to think
of it this h6 move was maybe saying you
know what let me make a useful move well
I don't know how useful it is right now
but more long-term it's a flight square
and in a sense it's a bit of a waiting
move huh yeah they were waiting they
they wanted they wanted me to play this
then that would give them one moment to
play Bishop e7 castle because I don't
have direct pressure on g7 anymore and
on Knight here now this and I can't get
to d5 so easily I have to backtrack
which means that the computer suggestion
rip d1 starts to make much more sense
half opened file and we have not yet
come into the night so this question
still stands what are you doing with the
bishop if you play e5 then it's a very
quick journey to d5 okay so rip d1 would
have been better there
b5 never hit I'm just focusing on the
light squares here it likes Knight d5
right away I'm one point to advantage
Knight d5 I played rip to c1 I'm a bit
curious on this how do in which way to
recapture that's approaching a to pawn
advantage I likes it takes Knight before
rook c1 what maybe this as an idea and
then breaking down on this also the
knight is ready to be trapped so ace a 5
is a retreat for the night
a5 did it just pop up a knight here for
a moment
give the knight a kick and then you
could already sacrifice here oh boy oh
it doesn't even end wow that's very
crushing huh just brute brute force play
here and opening up lines Kings still in
the middle sacrificing a minor piece but
it really isn't a sacrifice I mean I'm
getting a lot of material d6 and can't
move the Bishop Bishop takes Bishop
takes with check whoa okay so that's
interesting
to immediately drop into d5 in other
words an arm takes to take like this and
then have ideas of a piece sac on e5
I was thinking night to be a but this is
still hitting Wow okay that's good to
know
so I prepped I tried to prep it a little
bit with rook c1 and clean those back
but now I black started to a fight back
here and the c5 I did not consider at
all that's what it's calling for I take
c5 Knight d2 something's lost with that
okay
still a half pawn advantage but yeah I
was a little bit concerned about 94 he's
pretty much intolerable then Knight f3
there would be this right
ooh even this smell actually yeah this
would have scared me actually I want to
just take the night what about this move
okay I'm taking here yeah okay that
wouldn't be good okay so I guess I would
get that d4 pawn is the short story if
the knife lays in here
the bishop doesn't have this square to
defend the pawn so easily the Knights
there
okay so Queen e2 and then this is where
there's gonna be a big jump I believe
Bishop takes Knight and I'll jump it off
close to a pawn advantage but it feels
like it's so much more the have the
light square control very active rook
pressure against d6 and this is my only
vulnerable point Queen b6 huh in the
game is Queen f6 and it was much easier
to defend the pressure against f2 Queen
b6 hitting it in a way where the pawn is
now pinned uh-huh calls out for the very
direct c5 I don't know that I would have
played that I think what is quite
natural is Queen here but this is quite
difficult to actually ooh that isn't
even working because of this Bishop e3
move how about that well that's a good
one Queen e2 is not defending f2 sneaky
Bishop move so c5 very easily fallen for
that and then rook here pawn here stuff
with a hitting f2 I could always take
with check and then even allow my bishop
to defend okay interesting after Queen
f6 it really started to feel like it was
in the bag but I did not like how I
converted it at the
here I reference Bishop f4 with Queen h4
I could immediately kick him out g3 King
g2 similar to how I played it in the
game just covering f3 also watching over
f4 okay I didn't go for that played
Bishop a3 and that is the best move in
the computer's eyes to play Queen f4 but
uh I mean it is trading and black is
going to be down story alive wasn't
needed I don't think g3 is so bad though
it's still holding something yeah this
is what concerned me just a little bit
is this Bishop check and I didn't want
to go in the corner because that renews
back rank possibilities and this move
allows maybe e4 no it doesn't the rook
has to be guarded so that was just silly
to not just see this and there isn't
time for does e4 move okay
did you eat three anyhow did it ever
slip here I went in for the capture and
I guess that's still fine this is fine
as well and on that move yeah I mean
it's reading as +3 f4 but you really
shouldn't even allow this type of
counter play well you know what's strong
this rook here yeah this is this is
crushing actually focusing on the g7
squared who cares about the a poner the
H pawn I'm going right after the heart
of that structure at g7 hmm okay but if
if I could do it over again I wouldn't
even have wanted to allow this type of
counter play is what I'm getting at
I would have preferred this and you know
the rook can't make use of some other
files
easily rook here what can I do for this
well this idea is actually just weight
which is perfect I secured the bishop
and then threatened to enter on the
seventh and then a black is broken down
very quickly okay yeah I only saw this
much later this idea of putting pressure
on g7 only I think it was right around
right around here did I miss anything
evaluation wise now it's still holding
something upon and a half for yeah you
know here's one other detail I'd like to
get each foreign keep these on dark
squares and this provides a nice home
for my king there's never any worry of
some bishop coming in here stuff you
notice if the pawn is here I'm maybe in
a situation where there could be a
mating net but I just grabbing some
space h5 essentially secures my king a
nice position on g4 so you really can't
be dislodged so easily but uh anyhow
have four first now just invading here
famous any mates okay yeah and this is
where that there was the time lost but
tau three pounds plus and you know how
to convert it plenty of ways simplify
trade and push those pawns okay
interesting game as usual feel free to
leave any feedback in the comments
section below to this standard game this
fifteen to game and I'll catch you in
the next one that's all for now take
care
you